ein herzliches hallo und einen schönen
vormittag von der nici dem carry und von
mir heute tag 2 unseres online workout
trainings gestern war ein
intermittierende rumpf zirkel am
programm wir haben gewechselt zwischen
belastung und bewegung heute machen wir
ein kraft ausdauertraining wo man
wirklich auf 45 sekunden belastung haben
mit unterschiedlichen übungen und danach
wirklich 45 sekunden pause es heißt ohne
bewegung das ist der unterschied zu
gestern ja das ganze ist so vorbereitet
dass es wieder für unterschiedliche
leistungsbereiche gut passen wird und
wenn sie jetzt mit macht wie gesagt das
schaffen was gemeinsam mit aus dem lokal
zu kommen
wir freuen uns einfach cool ist work
katja und ihr gesagt wir fahren an glos
wir fahren gern mit bewegen am stand
haben wir ganz locker bewegen
genau dass man den kreislauf in schwung
bringen ist ganz wichtig da immer wieder
die variante hineinbringen knie anheben
genial fersen alles ist möglich
das macht man so ganz grob ungefähr 30
sekunden dann gehen wir in eine
mobilisation dass man auch mal glas
nächstes für das sprunggelenk das heißt
auf der zehenspitze wir beginnen mit dem
rechten bein greisen fünf mal nach
rechts 500 links nicht nur die gelenke
wie gesagt gehören vorher hätte dass man
verletzungsfrei durch das workout kommen
der ganze körper der kreislauf ist beim
aufwärmen damit dabei seite wechseln
bitte ja war fünfmal schoss auf der eine
seite fünf mal auf die andere seite
genau und wir gehen wieder an dynamik
wir gehen in den boxer live hinein
ganz grob 30 sekunden boxer love
na gut wir mobilisieren das kniegelenk
beide beine schließen hände auf das knie
fünf kreise links fünf kreise rechts
sodass nichts wie dort bitte ab und zu
ein knacksen im gelenk glaube ist okay
vertretbar aber schmerzen sollte keiner
haben ja wenn fertig stellen wir wieder
auf habe männer bitte teilweise die
übungen kennt sie schon gestern
teilweise kommen neue übungen dazu ja
also es wird das wechsel drinnen sein
auch hier wieder unterschiedliche
varianten natürlich möglich die hast
eine übung steht sprung im arm mit
anstoßen genau
jawohl wir kommen zur hüftgelenk
mobilisieren wir drehen das rechte bein
in einem großen kreis nach hinten
daher wollen wir drehen es nach vor
[Musik]
wenig ist noch ganz in boxen dringt hat
die deckung fast nur oben er wolle das
passt da wir wechseln die seite wird
reden wieder nach hinten das muss
natürlich das kam sportlerherz frank
gehry oder baloise jawohl wir drehen
nach vor
ja aber kurz aus lockern wir kreisen das
becken auf die rechte seite wir beginnen
diesen mit ganz kleinen kreisen werden
immer größer im zuge von 45 kreisen und
dann werden wir wieder kleiner
wer durch ist mit einem richtung von
klein auf gross wechselte auf die andere
die beweglichkeit ist da nicht immer so
große kreise jan o
er war kann man schon sehr gehört und
wir bleiben widerstehen
genau wir bewegen uns wieder wir laufen
am stand jetzt macht man kurzen
tempowechsel das heißt wirklich am stand
laufen und wenn ich so kommt wäre es ein
bisschen schneller
und wenn ich sage wieder stoppt nicht
aufhören sondern weiter bewegen ok also
weiter bringt genau haben wir manchmal
so aus stoff sehr gut
optimal passt gut hilfsbereit verstand
körper nach vor und wir vertreten den
oberkörper nach links und rechts ist
dass der rumpf beugen rumdrehen in der
vorbeugend haben wir gestern aufgehört
die übung ist bekannt bei viel
beweglichkeit oder büro mehr
beweglichkeit geht es bis zu den
zehenspitzen auswahl schon ein paar
jährchen am buckel hat geht es
vielleicht nochmal bis zum knie und wir
richten uns wieder auf hamann wieder
gleich wieder mit dem wechsel variante
vor zurück und auf und zu
was von oben von unten herauf begonnen
hüfte wirbelsäule haben wir ganz gut mit
wasser jetzt mal vorträge schultern
seien ganz wichtig genau die brauchen
wir beim ganzen berg hat immer mit dabei
oberen extremität der bis jetzt kreis
man mal die arme vorwärts wir fangen wir
gleich mit einem großen kreis an werden
klein und schnell in den bewegungen und
dann werden wir wieder groß und so
langsam gehen und wir wechseln die
richtung werk reisen nach hinten und
kein motorrad ist schnell wieder klein
werden so dass man bislang dynamisch da
drinnen haben dass der körper
wirklichkeit vorbereitet ist auf die
belastung die jetzt folgt genau sagen
lässt das gelenk also letzter teil
bereich den man noch zum aufwärmen haben
ist unser nacken die nackenmuskulatur
dass man keine verspannungen vom
training mit nehmen genau wie ich fahren
gerne an wir wollen das kind über die
brust von der linken auf die rechte
seite und wieder zurück das kann man
ruhig 234 mal machen
jawohl
dann gibt man den kopf von der linken
auf die rechte seite
wie gesagt so dass er schmerzfrei
basiert das ganze ohne schwung schön
langsam hin und her gehen
dann schau mal von der linken auf die
rechte seite und letzte bewegung nach
vorne und nach oben dann haben wir
ziemlich alle teilbereiche da heißt wir
müssen auch mobilisiert und ich gesagt
wir seien bereit für unser werk bereit
dann legen wir mit unserem werk ratlos
wir werden das ganze machen mit 45
sekunden belastung und 45 sekunden pause
solltet ihr generell fragen zum workout
oder zu sportlichen themen haben unsere
sportwissenschaftler der doktor aus
sitzt wieder vor dem beziehung die
schreiberei tja also beantwortet gerne
jede frage die kommt wir fangen an mit
kurzen vorzeigen der ersten übung dann
machen wir die übung und in der pause
kriegt sie dann immer wieder
nächste übung präsentiert also die erste
übung biete 12 ausfallschritte wir haben
zwei varianten variante nummer eins ihr
geht es in die position und geht es
hinunter und hinauf knie berührt nicht
den boden und das vordere knie gibt
nicht nach vorne sondern die bewegung
kommt vom hinteren bei nach unten
variante nummer zwei ist etwas
dynamischer wir steigen immer wieder
dazu in die position und wechseln die
seite ok bei der zweiten wahl also bei
der ersten variante machen wir das ganze
noch 20 bis 25 sekunden seitenwechsel
dass man beide seiten belastet haben
alle teams bereit mein thema ist es wir
starten in drei zwei eins und los gibt
und übung geht schon los
genauso wichtig dabei ist dass man immer
wieder seine beinachse kontrolliert das
heißt wenn man in den ausfallschritt
geht sollte das knie nicht nach innen
oder nach außen weg treffen sondern
sollte in einer ebene bleiben mit dem
sprunggelenk und mit der hüfte
das ist ein wichtiger punkt so
seitenwechsel bitten khedira kann
einfach weitermachen
genau jawohl und man fängt meistens mit
der besseren seite an das heißt wenn wir
jetzt den wechsel hat und es klemmt der
bislang am anfang kein problem
man kommt ja schon rein und wie gesagt
diese 20 bis 25 sekunden pro seite
timmer jetzt haben das funktioniert ganz
gut
45 sekunden vorbei pause kurz aus
lockern nächsten übung die man machen
ist eine bauch übung der lakers das
heißt gary bietet sagen wir zwar vorlegt
ja mal am rücken streckt die beine aus
gerne auf der gerade diese
kompliziertere die schwierigere variante
mit den händen bitte in die luft nicht
hinterm kopf verschränken und erhebt
seine beine bis ganz nach oben und senkt
sie wieder ab und es immer so dass die
lendenwirbelsäule am boden bleibt wenn
ihr mit der lendenwirbelsäule vom boden
abhebt dann ist die übung zu schwer dann
machen wir die bislang schlechtere
variante indem er die hände um das gesäß
hineinlegen dann geht es ganz einfach
sei das
geschlossen blieben januar und leute
sowie gestern ich habe es gestern schon
gesagt auch heute
wir haben täglich um 7 oder 30 unsere
pcr-test wir wissen wir sind corona
negativ deswegen können wir die abstände
der relativ gering halten und auch mit
berührungen arbeiten wir sagen getestet
da ist alles gut
so habe gerne stars aber anstrengend
aber wir haben das spiel jetzt nicht bei
dir spürt man gut also eher sechs wir
haben zwei varianten eine variante sieht
jemanden zu anstrengend werden man kann
natürlich die knie auch abwinkeln ja
nicht gesagt oder gerne zeigt das einmal
vor das heißt sie kann jetzt dann
natürlich die übung ein bisschen
variieren sie den oberkörper hoch und
wir sagen er schon wieder in der pause
44 sekunden verlängern so schnell da ist
überhaupt kein thema wir wollen ich habe
schon mehr erwähnt ich werde nicht
wieder es noch einmal zu sagen in jedes
militärische wirklichkeit irgendeiner
liegestütz variante und das ist genau
unser nächste übung ja wohl wirklich
dafür bieten sagen der arme liegestütz
vor bitte an der an der schräge ihr
kennt das zuhause natürlich klassisch am
boden machen ihr kennt das angelehnt an
der mauer machen angelehnt an tisch
machen so kann man mit der höhe des
oberkörpers variieren sowie die
intensität dadurch verändert wichtig ist
dass schulter hüfte und sprunggelenk
immer eine ebene haben einmal runter
einmal auf wir wollen die übung sollte
bekannt sein da haben wir überhaupt kein
problem da gehrig reister dessen breiter
damit haben wir muskulär workflows ja
damit man muss cholera bislang
veränderungen haben bekommt man mit den
breiten greifer bisschen mehr in die
brust über die brust über seine sorge in
dem brustmuskel hinein und in der
schmalen schmalen griffs einmal diesem
rezept drinnen im an strecker eine
kleine anekdote am rande war schätzt
zwischen liegestütze hat algerien seiner
allerbesten also mittlerweile seien in
der besten zeit aber in der allerbesten
zeit schafft ganz verraten also
dokumentiert auf einem leistungs
prüfungsprotokoll 120 ja und das ist der
wert alle achtung eine gewisse diaz was
ist ein maximum an liegestütze machen
35 begangen aber immer ja und wenn man
sie speziell darauf vorbereitet ist
natürlich an mehr drin 21 orders wir
sind wieder in der pause so wie gestern
heute jederzeit in der pause trinkt
einen schluck ja das ist überhaupt kein
problem
der oberkörper aufrechten in der
bauchlage wechsel nie da fragst der
pause glaube ich oberkörper ziemer hoch
nicht mit schwung arbeiten sondern mit
der muskelkraft aus dem bereich der
lendenwirbelsäule muskulatur hochziehen
die etwas schwierigere variante ich
nehme die beine mit das heißt ich
streckte 10 aus aber wie gesagt ich darf
nicht mit schwung hoch reißen sondern
muss mit der kraft meiner muskulatur
arbeiten das ist ganz wichtig damit man
da keine verletzungen davon ziehen was
thorsten kurzawe bei den drei sekunden
geht schon wieder los
los gehts ja wohl auch hier der kopf der
heißt es immer in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule
wir schauen nicht nach vorne wir über
strecken nicht wir gehen nicht mit dem
kind zum boden sondern wir arbeiten da
langsam kontrolliert und spüren die
muskelspannung im bereich rückenstrecke
ja im bereich der lendenwirbelsäule
hauptsächlich jawohl schaut sehr gut aus
mehr es ist noch ein bisschen
schwieriger machen möchte kann natürlich
hat die hände ausstrecken und übrigen
beide anscheinend sich schwieriger
machen ja wohl variante eher in die
richtung rückwärts am hintern greifen
nicht sagt tausend varianten wichtig ist
dass wir nicht reißt ja pause vier
übungen hammer fünfte übung ein
klassiker unter den eigenen
körpergewichts übungen die kniebeuge das
quad da gibt es ab der auf die immer
aufpassen muss nicht machst du mal bitte
eine kniebeuge frontal bitte ja wohl
sehr gut wichtig ist auch hier die
beinachse das ganze mittlerweile das
knie das sprunggelenk die hüfte bleiben
in einer ebene dresden mal bitte 90 grad
zu mir jetzt noch mal runter auch
wichtig ist dass der rücken schon
aufrecht bleibt
ob ihr die hände in vor heute habt oder
dynamisch mitbewegt es ist mir ganz egal
die schritt breite 321 rackert geht los
kniebeugen die schritt breite wollte
noch reinbringen ist nicht so tragisch
against reiter stehen erkennen sie durch
chmelar stehen wichtig ist dass die
zehenspitzen ganz leicht geöffnet sein
genau da gibt es natürlich
unterschiedliche tiefen wo man kniebeuge
machen kann
ich kann eine tief kniebeuge machen wo
das gesäß wirklich ganz am boden unten
ist ich kann halt kniebeugen machen und
wenn es von der beweglichkeit ja nein
anders funktioniert scheider coole
viertel kniebeuge wie gar keine
ja also jede form der bewegung ist
natürlich der super wie er es braucht ja
um sich körperlich wirklich zu fordern
und zu belasten kann gesprungene
kniebeugen machen ist aber für euch
nicht unbedingt notwendig normale knie
waren gleich zwei mal 45 sekunden vorbei
letzte übung führen ersten durchgang
machen wir tipps haben wir wieder was
für ein oberkörper mit dabei gerne bis
bereit zwei sekunden zum durchschnaufen
dass die zeitnehmer uns ja wohl bei
gerrit sagt euch jetzt die variante
krebs vorne zeigen wie leicht vor das
heißt wir greifen am sessel oder auf der
bank oder an tisch hinten uns irgendwann
gehen mit den beinen nach vor und gehen
runter und hinauf vielmehr winkel im
knie dass der einfache gestreckte der
körper wird desto schwieriger wird
ja und da gerne wird dann in der
bewegungs phase in der work out phase
nur ganz schwierige variante zeigen okay
die aber bitte nicht nachmachen sondern
die lawson haus 21 uhr los geht's hier
setzt die wirklich schwierige hardcore
variante beine erhöht und tief runter
und wieder rauf wie gesagt bitte dass
der hahn nicht nachmachen sessel kann
wegrutschen unsere boxen die wir dort
seien relativ massiv die stehen relativ
gut aber die variante die die nici mit
da macht ist die perfekte variante um
dort die muskulatur richtig zu
trainieren
geht's noch leere oder wie es die zweite
variante jahr nehmen gegner fast machine
zehn sekunden noch nach drei erster
durchgang vorbei wir haben zwei minuten
pause die zeit nutzen bringt zum schluss
laut mirror
ja wir trainieren wie ich schon gesagt
habe
mit quasi leistungssportlern wir
trainieren mit einsatzsoldaten wir haben
ein sehr breites portfolio was man
anbieten wir brechen das werk dort so
herunter das ist zuhause mitmachen
kannst ja und wir sagen doch in der
praxis ja und wenn er was zu sport
theorie hören möchte jetzt von unseren
leistungssportlern es gibt den sport
podcast tennissport rapport den man auf
youtube auf spotify auf dem apple
podcast beziehungsweise auf dieser auch
nachhören kann
da führt bei andreas on air die
interviews und alle 14 dort kommt dann
neuer sportler der seiner
trainingserfahrung und trainings praxis
einfach berichtet lohnt sich auf alle
fälle hinein zu kriegen ja dagegen macht
sie gerade bereit um zu zeigen wie
soldaten fitness auch richtig
funktionieren kann
mit zusätzlicher belastung das heißt der
hat da eine gewichts weste jetzt
unglaublich schwer ist genau 9,2 killer
ist eine zusatzbelastung der mann da mit
herumträgt wer jetzt glaubt 19 kilo es
endet für probiert zusammen heraus was
sagt über hinten rücken bei den
liegestützen einer heute dass sie gibt
schon ganz anders aus normalerweise
bleiben alle übergewichts meiste aber
eben wie gesagt um auch zu zeigen hat
die nötigen ausgelöst hat die gewichts
westen aus sondern sind auch die normale
variante dass man beide varianten wieder
abdecken aber gesagt rein körperlich ist
natürlich bei beiden bringen
ja ja wie gesagt sportliche fragen auch
jederzeit an den doktor aus der sie zu
hause und beantwortet fleißig eure
fragen und natürlich auch im nachhinein
noch so etwas unter den fingernägeln
brennen jederzeit möglich wie gesagt 30
sekunden hamann pause ist gleich vorbei
wir schauen dass nur den kreislauf
wieder in schwung bringen das heißt
spätestens jetzt bitte aufstehen kurz
bewegen anstand ein bisserl
vorbereiten wieder wir starten dann
nehme ich gleich wieder mit der ersten
übung mit den ausfall schritten macht
sich bereit
ja wieder die unterschiedlichen
varianten 20 bis 25 sekunden die eine
dann die andere seite aber ihr jetzt
schon mit den wechsel drei sekunden 21
rackerten geht schon aus 45 sekunden mit
dem platten träger wie chop gar nicht so
einfach auch die stabilität aus den
beinen entsprechend zu halten die
beinachse zu halten
der piaggio der kirche wirklich was dazu
ich bin als kampfsportler schwer
begeistert die deckung hält ja bei jeder
bewegung wo die hände frei sein ist die
deckung da das passt gut seitenwechsel
lag lehre möchte ich nicht noch schwerer
machen indem er die hände hinter dem
kopf gibt man kann es ja nach oben
strecken ja dann hat man bei sowas von
rücken an mit dabei wie auch hier
tausend varianten börsengang vielleicht
gehört pause 45 sekunden
wir wechseln wieder von der belastung
der beine auf den bauch das heißt dass
beine heben in der position an rücken
liegend mit den varianten beine strecken
hände unter dem gesäß mit der variante
hände vorne so wie man es im ersten
durchgang auch gemacht haben und wenn
immer nur dabei sein
damen hoch dann gehen wir da richtig gas
ja 15 sekunden kennst langsam die
position einnehmen dass man von unserer
kostbaren zeit des workouts quasi nichts
versäumen nur zwei sekunden pause
braucht nimmt es natürlich aber wir
starten in fünf sekunden
drei zwei eins und los geht's
genau wenn es geht gerne die fersen ganz
zum bono unter fenster auch noch hergibt
und wieder hoch ohne schwung aus den
oberkörper diesmal bitte ja wahrhaftig
erkämpft ja es ist schon richtig
anstrengen damit der gewichts westen und
versucht die beine nicht mit schwung
nach unten fallen zu lassen sondern auch
da gut gegenhalten abbremsen nicht dass
die fersen am boden deponiert sondern
das jetzt maximal kurz antippte und
gleich wieder hoch hebt das der
bauchmuskel wirklich permanent an feier
permanent unter belastung
ich sage wenn da brennt das ist gut so
dann kehrt es so gelassen sehen sekunden
bei piano durch heute als natur ja
wieder eine übungs variante zu meiner
rechten 21 und pause sehr gut
kurz aus lockern die liegestütze macht
man auch mal nicht die dafür die
vielleicht bieten haben normale
liegestütze auf der matte mit
blickrichtung nach vorne also frontal
dass man die unterschiedlichen griff
breiten kurz demonstrieren gleich einmal
ganz breit genau als einmal sehr stark
ein brustmuskeln vector alles drinnen
rauf und runter normale liegestützen
schulterbreit die standard-variante sehr
gut auch hier der kopf immer in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule und dann
gibt es noch die ganz schmale variante
das ist dann wirklich schwierig und wenn
es braucht man jetzt sagen danke hände
übereinander gibt ja dann ist am
allermeisten der trizeps belastet jetzt
45 sekunden
für linke stützt auch an der mauer in
der schräglage natürlich möglich dann
nimmt man dann ein bisschen druck außer
zuschauen schön tief runter so dass der
ellbogen der oberarm mit der schulter
eine ebene bildet ja das heißt das ja da
beim runtergehen wirklich eine gerade
habt und dann wieder hoch drücken
ok dann hat die richtige tiefe ja aber
schaut sehr gut aus gary 15 sekunden
noch nicht geführt die aber du wirkst du
etwas weniger angestrengt wieder gerne
gerade also da mache ich mir weniger
sorgen
sie konnten
sie konnten und das war es gerrit ackers
berlin bleiben weil die nächste übung
ist jedes oberkörper aufrichten aus der
bauchlage brauchen wir jetzt viel
variieren
debug lage ist aber die anderen haben
bloß nischenplayer also wie gesagt
deswegen bin ja jeder dass sie das immer
wieder auch ausbessern kann genau wir
richten den oberkörper auf die eine
variante zweite variante wir nehmen die
beine wieder mit wobei die knie bitte
durchstrecken wäre genau das meine
schönen heber drin haben und nicht mit
schwung mischung passte danke ich glaube
wir haben es wieder verstanden um was es
geht kurze pause für beide nur 19
sekunden geht schon wieder los
und das ist die dritt vorletzte übung
also genau drei übungen dann ist das
workout wieder beendet drei sekunden so
eines wie konkret retter und gas aber
nicht mit schwung reisten haben gesagt
ja sondern mit der kraft der muskulatur
hochziehen
ja aber ich gehe hier hat man vielleicht
ein bisserl atmen der ist wirklich gut
belastet
das schaut uns ja klar 25 sekunden haben
wir also halbzeit groupies erreicht
rückenstrecke ist belastet das ist gut
die b säule wird stabilisiert ja wohl
die letzten zehn sekunden
[Musik]
und passt und oft vor letzte übung wir
machen wieder die kniebeuge vielleicht
jetzt einmal für euch zu hause als
variante versuchen ein bisschen breiter
zu stehen und man den muskulären druck
ein bisschen zu verändern
das heißt wir kennen es ruhiger um eine
gut ausladende position haben tief und
hoch kommen wobei der wichtig die
beinachse muss in jeder variante stimmen
wurscht ob ich jetzt mal oder bereit
stehe ja jetzt so was man bei der
kniebeuge achten muss nicht rücken
gerade genau
ja da brauch ist immer angespannt bei
jedem training ist der bauch anspannen
also die rumpfmuskulatur thema gestern
trainiert haben ja die arbeit bei jedem
training mit die ist immer aktiviert
zwei sekunden anders geht es 65 sekunden
kniebeugen wie gesagt die hände vor dem
körper die hände dynamischen mitnehmen
das ist alles gut solange der bauch und
rücken in einer grundspannung ist der
oberkörper gerade bleibt und die
beinachse stimmt sagt schon ganz gut
beieinander
sie schauen wir diese dame von vorn an
okay das war doch was so alles okay ja
genau schön auf die beinachse achten
schöne nach außen drücken das knie gerne
15 sekunden hat es noch drei sekunden 21
und ausgänge wieso braucht dass er dort
die kniebeugen bei welchen bewegungen
ist es ganz wichtig heben und tragen ja
wohl brauche die power aus dem
oberschenkel genauso ist es überwinden
von hindernissen wenn irgendwo darüber
muss das dann alles energie bis als
energie gebraucht aus meiner
oberschenkelmuskulatur
deswegen ist ja bei uns ganz wichtig und
wird stark trainiert leute 15 sekunden
pause habe es nur dann geben die
allerletzte übung hinein und es seien
wieder die tipps ja und ich bin gespannt
ob der kehre mittelgewichts westen jetzt
die wirklich wirklich hardcore variante
markt oder diebe soll normalere aber so
wie in kenn ja es gibt eigentlich egger
diskussion ja und jetzt schauen dass wir
möglichst was das schultergelenk an
beweglichkeit hergibt in die tiefe geht
so dass es aber immer noch halten kann
stabilisieren kennt muskulär jahr also
nicht soweit einigen was von der
beweglichkeit her theoretisch möglich
wäre zudem ist es heute kennen ja wenn
die muskulatur da nicht heute dann wäre
das nicht gut
19 sekunden es ist fast vorbei
die letzten zehn sekunden haben wir gas
geben zu hause war
5 432 ja wohl genau leute workout nummer
zwei kraft ausdauer training mit dem
eigenen körpergewicht ist ein neuer
erledigt das was wir jetzt noch machen
zum schluss ist eine kurze abwehr phase
damit man den kreislauf an die
möglichkeit geben sich zu erholen und
nicht sofort sagen jetzt ist aus sondern
jetzt machen wir nur lockeres auslaufen
am stand der firma man es gibt die
möglichkeit natürlich dass über bewegung
zu machen über die atmung zu machen kann
sehr viel mit dem kopf steuern gibt es
unterschiedliche varianten einen guten
zu machen wir fangen jetzt einmal wie
gesagt mit lockerer bewegung an
mit ausschütteln mit aus lockern danach
stehen bleiben
tief einatmen tief ausatmen jeder in
seinem rhythmus einfach schauen dass die
die atmung sie wieder beruhigt und
normalisiert ich kann mein oberkörper
natürlich entsprechend durchstrecken ich
kann das einfach nur tief in den bauch
und brustbereich einatmen und wieder
ausatmen unterschiedlichste varianten
möglich ja immer wieder zwischendrin ein
bisschen bewegen ausschüttung den
oberkörper vielleicht noch ein bisschen
verdrehen die muskulatur einfach wieder
zur ruhe kommen lassen ja also bei der
niki hat man aber beim bemerkt man die
atmung wird wieder ruhig ich glaube wir
sagen am richtigen weg
jawohl zügel weiter lockert nummer zwei
wie gesagt haben wir abgeschlossen jetzt
haben wir zwei tage wirkliche belastung
hinter uns gestern mit dem rumpf
krafttraining heute mit dem kraft
ausdauertraining morgen gehen wir sehr
viel ruhiger an morgen schauen wir uns
das gleichgewicht und die koordination
hat islam um 10 uhr 30 geht das ganze
los und solltet ihr das heutige werk hat
es erst ganz zum schluss eingeschalten
haben oder das gestrige versäumt haben
auf youtube findet ihr die beiden works
natürlich zum nachsehen und ja wie
gesagt wir dann morgen sicher da 12 30
jahre und und wir würden uns freuen wenn
ihr morgen arbeitet aussetzt dankeschön
und bis morgen